hallo ich bin die jenny und ich würde
gerne wissen was denn dein peinlichste
augenblick war halo jenny mein teil
nächste augenblick in bezug auf die
musik war dass ich mir beim allerersten
auftritt im jahr 2000 beim doomsday
festival morgens nach dem aufstehen wo
ich noch total verpennt war mein bart
abrasiert habe ich habe das nicht
gemerkt und bin da ganz normal zu den
musikern gegangen zur probe und
irgendwann gucken nämlich ja
irgendwie anders ausgeht bei dir du hast
ja diesen dreiecks bart abrasiert und da
ist mir dann ganz kurz heiß und kalt
geworden und haben wir dann kurz vor dem
auftritt einen schwarzen edding genommen
und habe mir die dinger einfach angemalt
und es hat keiner gemerkt und das war
mein peiniger augenblick in dem moment
und alle haben sich totgelacht hinter
der bühne aber die zuschauer haben zum
glück nichts gemerkt